i'm good are you
good a little sleepy but
marshall bro do you want to do me a
quick favor
yeah just for the viewers bro let's
let's get that lens clean man
there we go and there we go
we want to see that beautiful face bro
allah mubarak man how's your night going
alhamdulillah
it's okay it's okay how are you
good bro let's uh get through some of
these comments and then tell them why
we're here
all right
no they know why we're here
yeah you're right bro they should know
where
[Music]
[Music]
if you guys uh
you don't know who paul is or blogging
theology go over and check out his
channel subscribe
wonderful work he's doing masha allah
alaykum salaam
that's the goal of the community
alhamdulillah on hell inshallah and
he'll be on very soon
all right
while we're here we're gonna get to that
in just one minute
where's charizard
that's funny charizard's on the way
okay i'm the last so
i don't want to say big announcement but
semi-big for anyone that's
here wondering what we're doing we are
trying to
introduce and implement something new to
our channel
inshallah so it's going to be call-in
shows where we paste the link
of our stream and anyone can join right
um we didn't quite decide yet the
logistics about it so if we're going to
allow anyone and everyone to join or if
it's going to be something where it's
like members only
patrons only or whatever
inshallah for today we already have a
few of our
loyal subscribers lined up that want to
make it on the show
and we're more than honored to host them
however
at the end of that if we run out of time
let's say or we have extra time we might
then paste the stream just to the public
all right but inshallah rami what's on
your mind
now much to be honest i'm very excited
alhamdulillah to be able to talk to some
viewers insha'allah as this girls i
think we're probably going to get some
people that don't like us very much
and i'm even more excited for that
definitely bro definitely i see a lot of
people like ef dawah right they do that
hamza's then you know they always have
people that come on try to challenge
them so i want to make it clear that
we're not opposed to anyone if you want
to come and you want to be respectful
right one thing we're not going to do
we're not going to be children
and arguing or or being immature and
childish that's what we're going to do
if you want to respectfully challenge
your views if you want to come say hi
come say salaam whatever you want to do
inshallah we'll be very open to that
why don't you take over the floor for a
minute while i send uh the link to some
of the people
all right inshallah
yeah i didn't have access to the the
webcam i usually use tonight
unfortunately
you guys can handle it
you can pin some of the comments and not
address them if you want bro yeah
insha allah
yes yes i have a lot of these
discussions on my tic toc live and every
time someone steps out of line i just
jump in
and uh kick them off if i have to so we
are definitely not afraid to do on here
you know come up disrespectful we'll
boot you off and you'll just lose the
opportunity
uh so i mean no point trying it
and again the same question where is
angel
um he should be on the way inshaallah
should be on the way
yes yes
there is a chance that you can get on
here insha'allah
yes you can you can ask your questions
believe it or not
my mentor believe it or not
i mean yeah that's something to uh to
boast about here on the podcast
inshaallah inshallah
i don't wanna
you know boost us too much bro
but alhamdulillah with the grace of
allah we've grown a lot in one year
and to anyone that doesn't know already
we don't plan on stopping
whatsoever insha allah
so if you do have this opportunity you
know the likelihood of anyone getting on
the stream is only going to decrease
over time and this is not me trying to
be uh egotistic or narcissistic or
anything like that but think about it if
we have way more people watching way
more subs then it only makes sense that
it's going to be much harder to get
everyone on and answer everyone's
questions so that's why if uh if you
guys made it today inshallah you can get
on
inshallah
all right so first question this is an
important question why does flat skin
look so buttery um it's actually not
butter but good try it's margarine
so
i i usually wake up every single morning
i take a tub of margarine i like to take
maybe like half a teaspoon no more than
that you don't want to get it like
glistening you know
and just just go to town bro just it's
good for the skin moisturizer you know
it's uh it's very deep exfoliating you
know for all the skincare peeps and i
highly recommend you guys get on there
it's also very cheap and affordable
inshallah
since it's all out we sent you uh the
link on instagram feel free to join
raw me bro go in
patchy beard man if you knew anything if
you know anything about me you know a
year or two ago
you'll know i
i would have been lucky to have a patchy
beard um
i barely had a beard but if you want a
beard what you got to do is you got to
get yourself a derma roller
d-e-r-m-a derma roller and you're going
to want to roll vertically horizontally
diagonally on the places that you want
to you know
enhance growth
then you're going to take some beard oil
something that also promotes growth and
you're going to rub it in
on the spot to do that for a year
consistently or at least on and off for
a little bit and you will find that one
day you have a nice beard inshallah
i look like a ghost
um maybe i am a ghost you don't know
maybe this is a gin in place of me
you don't know man
i'm having a panic attack i'm serious
about this
man
may allah make it easy for you
i mean just take deep breaths
relax
or at least try to remember that nothing
is as bad as it seems that things are
always worse in our head
find someone close that you love and
you know go and hug them or ask them to
give you a hug
and to bring you back down inshaallah
yeah all right so
we uh
we gave i gave the link to the four
uh wonderful peeps that wanted to make
it on the stream the brothers and
sisters so if you guys want to join go
for it but in the meantime i will post a
link right here on uh on the stream
i don't want bro this i don't know if
this is gonna be a bad idea i feel like
a ton of people are going to come
but
bismuth right is what it is
and guys genuinely come if you actually
have a question or something you know
don't just come and be like yo what's up
and then just like off it you know what
i mean
yeah that's the link
is looking so professional what am is
nice eh
yeah
what y'all think about that wi-fi
connection though oh it's chris bro i
could see you in like all the pixels bro
i'm gone
all right so sister mariam okay we got
like eight people here
uh
i'm just gonna quickly pause from stream
let's add
mic to taher but on her bro tommy taher
doesn't sound exactly like the brother
that you're with right now
i know this is the first time i spoke to
tyre bro
maybe you speak brother
oh i mean
i don't know what i mean sometimes
people sound similar sometimes people
look the same
a bit
i mean
believe it or not um the first time i
seen brother fayette over here i'm sorry
if i'm mispronouncing your name
um
was on brother gabriel's page i used to
follow him on uh facebook
and uh
he posted a picture and i was like is
that bow wow
like that was my first like
is he like you know because there was
like a whole thing about celebrities
going to dubai and you know going to
mosques and posting pictures i'm like
wait vawa's like what's going on like is
he becoming a muslim or something like i
don't know and that's actually that was
how
i came to
um find out about you guys and your
youtube channel and everything
so what time is it where you at bro
well new york city um 7 26 p.m
there we go same time zone
yeah same time zone same time zone east
what's going on what are you up to
tonight
nothing uh basically just finished work
uh at my office was waiting for you guys
to go live to get on conference and uh
take it from there you know
yeah
you know i mean you have to do what you
have to do
how about you brothers i mean i just
recently seen your uh trip to uh iceland
it's an old trip yeah but we just we
just uploaded because of a high demand
but inshallah we're going to go on some
more trips that are you know about three
of us inshallah
all right so we got the first comment
right now i'm going to pin it up right
now
yeah i think i got cut off
do you guys see the haya
that angel has mashallah
brother
i think taher was lagging for a bit
let's add uh the next one
maryam are you is it working now the
audio
system yeah it is
[Music]
17 what made you
end up on my stream today
um well actually i found you guys when
you just started out your youtube
channel alhamdulillah it stumbled upon
my
home page and since then i've been
listening to you ever since
you sound nervous though i hope you're
not nervous
i mean obviously a bit nervous yeah
i'm nervous
put on me bro
you got any questions for sister mariam
or
youngest
i guess participant in today's stream
well so far um so far
i was going to ask if she has any
questions for us
definitely um okay so i think if i could
ask you guys any one question it would
be relating to your youtube channel
because i myself would love to start my
own
because i feel like especially for
females and young females there isn't a
lot out there
yeah in terms of influencing islamic
influencing specifically so if you guys
have any tips that would be great
yeah that's great and i i really
appreciate and really respect um you
know a sister taking that kind of
initiative
because i was actually speaking to
someone recently about how this
lacks
in the
this guy
how it lacks in the dawah today the the
the lack of diaz uh on the sister's end
so i think from a quran sunday
perspective we should have some sisters
out there in sha allah
um even if your you know youtube channel
isn't specifically for dawah
it should still you know like you're
you're a young muslim allah i'm sure
that's going to come at one point or
another and that in and of itself is
dawa but in terms of actual advice on
how to grow your channel all i can tell
you because i want to pass it to the
actual professionals here masha'allah in
a second all i can tell you is start
with the right intention
and the right game plan according to the
quran sunnah
and uh
be passionate about it don't do it
because you know one day you're gonna
you know have a million subscribers and
be making millions of dollars don't do
it for that do it because you're
passionate about what you're posting and
that will take you miles inshallah
alhamdulillah for sure
um i actually september i left school
and i'm doing full-time trips
alhamdulillah so i wanted to do
something based around that you know
motivate especially the muslims of this
generation to continue doing hif and um
following the quran and sunnah so
definitely inshallah
inshallah i just want to quickly say
something right now that our studio
right now only allows up to ten people
on stream yards so if you're trying to
join the stream right now uh the it's
full so just wait you know i'm gonna
kick you know people out as soon as we
get them on and we finish the
conversation with them uh and as soon as
we finish with sister maryam we're gonna
put on the next one but my advice would
be simple just pray a lot of this takara
if it's meant to be it's gonna happen um
if it's not don't really fight it but
definitely do your best and it's a
wonderful idea to take the stance on
being an influencer in a world where
there's a bunch of
leaders that can't lead and they're
unfit to
i guess
influence people so
anyone that is you know trying to be a
positive proper influencer they have my
support inshallah
inshallah i was going to say
you could probably
look to start this with some other
sisters
because the whole process is just
smoother when you have more people
involved
um and it does take work so
i just want you know say that off the
rip
you know it's it's a it's a beautiful
thing what you're doing alhamdulillah
it does take work but like anything in
life
it all takes work anything good worth
having never comes easy
so
like all the brothers said here play the
sahara
make sure your niha
is set on point and then yeah
look to do is with uh
more sisters inshallah and if not by
yourself
all of you guys definitely it was very
helpful and um you guys should do stuff
like this again the live stream i like
it
we will it'll be a continuous thing
inshallah
inshallah okay
fight you muted
looking for that all right let's bring
on the next guest
how are you doing
how are you doing
so first comment i have is i'm i'm from
canada so
you know
just wanted to say
hi from quebec
first off
bonjour bro bonjour
from the south shore of montreal and uh
you know alhamdulillah like uh i would
say
when the pandemic hit
right that's the moment where i
really really got into the dean
you know and my background i
i went to a high school and grew up in
a high school environment where
i i mean at most there would be one
muslim in the school besides from me
right and so i've been i've been through
the
i don't know how to say it the
the the struggle of being a minority
right and you know everybody and all
even when the when the events would
happen in paris and stuff and all the
attention would be centered around
the two or three muslims that in the
school etc
and uh
alhamdulillah have grown to to be able
to have the strength
to uh
cope with with this kind of type of
attention and stuff
um but i i wanted to to have some advice
you know because
i see in my region at least a lot of of
young muslims have
have a lot of issues like standing up on
their identity
right especially with the the the system
around here and
people's mentalities and you know
there's a lot of pressure so i just
wanted to have some
some advice or any insight that you may
have
ah
well
one thing i want to say is you have to
first recognize that you're basically
walking the path of the prophet
salallahu he said in hadith
islam became as
it came as something strange
and it will return to being strange so
glad tidings to the strangers you are a
stranger in
not just you know quebec but in your
area in your city probably
and uh people are going to look at you
like you're a strange person but that's
okay because the apostle has already
said that that's what's going to happen
so we already know that
secondly
may allah reward you to make it easy for
you to carry out on this mission but see
it as a mission of dawa that's
essentially what it is all eyes are on
you right like your tupac
and now you have to really kind of
show up and show up if you become timid
and let people walk over you as a muslim
then they're going to think they can do
that to muslims and if you stand your
ground and you you know
explain to them what we believe as
muslims and why there's nothing wrong
with it and why there can't be anything
wrong with even from their perspective
in a lot of cases
then they won't have much of an argument
they'll be forced to respect you and
ultimately forced to respect other
muslims in your school and all the
muslims across the world
see as an opportunity
it really is and that's uh that's how i
i saw it and you know one thing that
that
reinforced my my love for the dean is
that coming from this background where i
saw
like all the wrong that would be done
when there's a when people live a life
without
dean without without any any
it
it really made me realize like i
remember i i got hit when the when the
covet pandemic hit
and we went into lockdown i i
i started thinking i was like man all
these distractions all these things
like if if if i was to to
to go tomorrow like what
what what would i be feeling right now
like
i would be i would be more than in the
state of shock instead of like a
shock or i would feel ashamed
you know and uh
it the
you see i i've had experiences
uh
seeing people
fall into drugs
and and and fall into the depression
because uh the the one of the biggest
problems especially i can only talk for
quebec one of the biggest problems uh
here is that they teach children
that uh essentially at the age of 14 or
13 they are three and and and they can
go around and explore the world world
and go into to their desires as much as
they want they're just exploring
and i've seen the effects of it and
having no limitations i mean i've seen
i've seen some some of the closest
people to me even even
go into such serious depressions at the
age of 16 or 15
right at the point where they had to
quit school
and go to a special school
and so all seeing all these things even
though
even though a lot of people and even a
lot of young muslims
fell into them
unfortunately
uh it's also on the flip side
a way to even reinforce the the the
conviction in the deen
and how it saves you from all these all
these
uh unfortunate things
yeah
that's very true and you know what use
that um in your dawah when it comes up
when you when you i'm going to say this
quickly because we don't have much time
and we have to move on soon but
when these people come at you with your
dean uh defend your dean and throw it
back in their face say like listen your
society has produced
high divorce rates high mental illness
and all these different things and then
throw back onto them islam will set you
free from these things on a you know
from suffering from it on a wide scale
absolutely and yeah to to end off i
really thank you
thank you guys in actually the entire
darwah community on on the internet the
the the work that is being done for
islam is immense and it's having a real
impact
much larger than you could even
imagine so may allah bless you for that
and
i just wish you a good evening
i was the one who said that i'm having a
panic attack
really why are you having a panic attack
um
there's actually not really a reason for
that but
i'm suffering from this condition where
the doctors say even themselves don't
know what it really is
and the last it was kind of okay the
last weeks but like for
you know it was not okay the last week
was
the last two days it has been extremely
harsh for me it wasn't able to sleep for
three days or something like that maybe
only a few hours
and so i'm having these weird ticks and
stuff like that but
i'm good
yeah
it's probably because you sleep
when we don't sleep it um
when we become sleep deprived
it makes us
less able to handle stress
and you become overwhelmed very easily
and when you become overwhelmed very
easily you tend to have panic attacks
you tend to have nervous takes
and just a whole other host of issues so
yeah
a little bit more complicated than that
but
today normally would have a call to
doctor or we did call the doctor because
um
yeah they told us to but somehow they
were
calling the wrong doctor
i'm good at 100
what i will say is uh i agree with angel
that sleep definitely does exacerbate
the symptoms of panic and anxiety uh so
does having a diet rich in processed
foods i know it's not so simple because
you know on a case-by-case basis a lot
of brothers and sisters their issues are
deeper than just you know these
nutritional or or sleep or you know
these types of things but these are
factors that play a huge role and to
anyone that i always recommend them you
know
whole food diet i got this from angel a
lot of sleep got this from experience if
you do these two things and you are
actually active most of the day not
sedentary
you will notice a tremendous drop in
anxiety and panic like insha'allah and
it's miraculous so anyone not doing
these three things do it and sis i
recommend it to you too
after that everything else can you know
definitely wait but i definitely think
these three are things you should get in
check
yeah i
definitely do value a good sleep
especially because i'm a highly
sensitive person and without good sleep
i just
everything just turns out to be very bad
in the end
by the way i'm actually from germany
we're about in germany
um do you know hanoka
no no
like
germany
north north west germany but so there's
this it's the biggest city in our
in in that area that i live in but we're
kind of like maybe like 20 kilometers or
something like that away from it
[Music]
well it was a pleasure you know speaking
with you uh jazakallahu for getting on
and i'm gonna keep you in my duas insha
allah you're stronger than any type of
anxiety or panic and everything is a
test from allah and it's our job to make
sure that we pass that's it
insha'allah
that's exactly currently doing because
that's why i said it's much more
complicated than that
um
but yeah
[Music]
i've been following you for a while now
and i really appreciate the word you do
and i don't know especially i'm 19 and
rami is 22 i guess i think probably
right
i'm turning turning 22 in august
okay and yeah with you guys it's just
like
it's just so good to see that people
from our age
are on the dean and you know being on
the rise and talking about all these
important stuff and stuff like that and
it's just really important for me
especially oh
yeah
i can really
identify with romney because um
kyle with with my story to islam it's
been kind of like a similar story
because
okay um and contradict you i might have
had a very strict upbringing when it
comes to the dean so
um
but
then i turned into atheists and stuff
like that but it was around when i was
16 that i really got came back to the
religion and the same as you're always
always listening to
lectures and stuff like that and this is
kind of what kept me on the pathway so
i'm very nervous
all right it was a pleasure salaam
alaikum
foreign
like my brother was like watching so i
kind of wanted to make like a surprise
visit you know
you made it you made it to t3
yeah okay i i wanted i have like a
question like a
question about like these like atheists
okay that like
try to ruin the name of like islam and
stuff can you guys like give me your
opinions of them like like apostate
prophet for example like i've seen this
guy and he gets the short like all the
time but like like when i first watched
him bro i was like so gullible bro and i
was like
yeah i was like not
i wasn't freaking out
can you guys just give me like your
opinions
yeah yeah that guy
there we go
that guy has extreme emotional damage
100
and um
maybe he gets some kind of funding for
doing what he's doing actually i know he
gets some kind of funding for you know
doing what he's doing
because that's the only way someone can
continue making a fool of themselves
over and over again if they're if
they're getting paid for it
uh so it's unfortunate
islam he has been
um smacked by daniel
he's been smacked by muhammad shah he's
been smacked by honestly so many
different people and um
it's sad to see someone who
you know talks so much about islam who's
been proven time and time again that
they're wrong about their their
conception about islam their claims
about islam
yeah it just seems like you'll never
accept it
yeah i think this is happening
as well
yeah so hello guys
um but i think that was like my biggest
concern but i love you guys so much you
know you guys are such a big inspiration
[Music]
tell your brother give him our salams
he's actually right over here
oh is he eyebrow bring him on let's go
one
i'm just gonna put you uh off the
waiting room just for a sec
all right
i'm mike
uh mike i know i'm mike i know bro i've
been seeing him since day one bro
commenting
so now i can bro you're muted
maybe he's he stepped away all right all
right our mic is going to be on pause
all right
hello jane salam
jane
hi conservative
um i wanted to
make a request
um can you make more revert stories they
have been very motivational for somebody
who was born a muslim
they kind of give me some push to be
better since i was born a muslim so
yeah can you make more of them
inshallah
stories motivate you then
the best review stories are is that of
the sahabah
because basically all of them are
reverts
so
i suggest if you haven't go listen to
the story of you know abu bakr of musa
ibn hummer of uh um
um and even ali who accepted it
basically as a child
this is a little you know really really
push you far insha'allah
thank you
all right
hello
for your suggestion inshaallah more
river stories to come have a good night
salam alaikum
all right all right all right
[Music]
yeah he's from my thursday class he just
joined i'm the love
so um i had a question for you guys like
i'm i'm in my first stage of like you
can see like so
improvement like self development and
so the thing is that i don't get the
results
sometimes and
uh so like i
i kind of like lose hope
but then i like
i want to i keep pushing myself so
so and and then what happens is that
sometimes i
kind of like get suicidal or something
but like so what's your advice for
people like me or
and yeah
baby
on angel go ahead bro go ahead go for a
man
i was gonna say consistency bro
allah always tests before you he gives
he's not just gonna give you what you
want right away
and uh the best example i can give this
is think about someone wanting to lose
weight they have a lot of fat on their
body
they need to put in the work they need
to eat less food so lower calories they
need to be doing some form of cardio
they need to be doing some form of
strength training and then they have to
stay consistent with that for months
on end
like and it's it's a process it's not
this like
it's not a linear process where you
start off like
stupid fat and then you
each week you're just going down down
down ah it's like sometimes you might go
two three weeks without losing any
weight
but you have to stay consistent because
if you stay consistent if you trust the
process
and you keep doing your part you keep
taking those steps forward you will
inevitably lose the weight you will lose
the fat and that goes with anything else
that you're going to do whether it be
self-improvement
whether it be learning something going
to school
learning more about the dean like allah
will test before he rewards
so just keep that in mind bro stay
consistent
yeah 100 100
and i also i want to add to that the
the growth isn't linear it's not
especially when you're dealing with like
the mental realm when you're talking
about you know suicide suicidal thoughts
depression anxiety all that i've
suffered from that as well bro so i know
exactly how you feel
uh alhamdulillah over time you know i
managed to get myself to a good place
and even you know once in a while i'll
to be completely honest once in a while
i'll slip back into like a depressive
episode or you know anxiety written
episode
and that's normal that's okay
uh but you do you know as anu said take
the steps to be consistent and keep
pushing yourself insha'allah
because it's not going to be linear
you're going to have amazing days you're
going to have horrible days and allah
says that he flips these days between oh
where'd the brother go oh bro i think we
lost him
it's okay
he can look back on the screen yeah on
the video once we post it and he'll get
his answer yeah
i'll just call him after a child yeah
one more thing for a lot of people
suffering with uh mental symptoms i just
wanna you know i understand what you're
going through because i've been through
it so if the brother is here usually
this is something you know a little bit
alternative but if the problem is in the
mind the solution is usually in the body
right one of the problems in the mind
people are thinking how do i think my
way into stress-free or just peace
usually the solutions in the body you're
not moving enough you're not active
enough or your diets there's a nutrition
problem there's a neurochemical
imbalance you know so that might just be
something that you guys should consider
inshallah
you put what um
[Music]
what would nama put on the screen or her
comment
but what oh okay
mom worked full-time four kids two jobs
writing books always on the go i went
through depression and suicidal thoughts
i know how you feel read quran fast a
lot go in nature drink more water i mean
[Music]
how's it going
how are you guys
good bro you sound a little out of
breath what's going on
oh no i'm not
thank you
i wanted to say uh i've been following
angel since back in the day when he was
talking about teaching
how to take cold showers and you know
all those self-building tips
so
back then i knew that islam was
the path for angel and alhamdulillah it
makes me so happy that
he you know joined the path of
you know perfection i would say
it makes me happy too
and back then uh actually in old videos
probably i left this book in the
comments uh i was recommend i would
recommend it to anybody it's a book that
uh
if anybody was to say
what book would you give to a non-muslim
to read to
learn about islam it would be this one
it's a book about self-building it's
about uh
through the teachings of
the prophets of allah and his family and
the quran
what is islam islam is a
path of
perfecting oneself we as human beings
have been sent down to earth what is the
purpose of our life once we determine
that purpose how do we go about it
practical steps so it goes from
theoretical to practical
and
you know
if you guys consider reading it
uh you know i'm sure
it will only help
it's called uh self-building by ibrahim
amini
it's changed my life and
i'm sure it will help a lot
in spreading islam
romney fight one of y'all want to write
that down
i have to have to get that name again
it's self building by
ibrahim
okay if it wouldn't be too much please
uh get us on instagram just send us a dm
and i'll be sure to you know make a
community post and recommend it
insha'allah inshaallah i want to take it
up
for your work
okay i just want to quickly say to malin
aki because you just became a member uh
check out our instagram story all right
i'll post to the streamyard link on our
instagram story at the three muslims one
word just like it's built on youtube uh
click the link to join the stream i'll
remember your name so as long as you
type that out i will let you in the
stream asap in sha allah
malaka he writes angel came along
yes
i had a beef with him at first but now i
got love for the king allah increase him
what'd you have beef with me for bro
that's what i don't wanna know yeah
malik bro let us know man type it up
all right
i love your energy bro i love your
energy what's going on
not much man um i just wanted to ask a
few questions in regards to that um
previously
um because we were talking that you guys
were talking about i believe in a video
that i watched um
about a there's a few videos i watched
but essentially i had just from one of
the videos i'll try to you know make
this concise but
uh
as someone especially for angel because
i'm not the kind of same like to the
last uh gentleman
um i've followed you for a long time bro
and i must say like you were like uh
somebody that i used to watch as far as
like the meditation um you know things
of that nature um as someone is just
more of a recent revert i just reverted
just yesterday um so come on
bro
uh you know i'm still kind of new to
everything so take a little easy on me
i'm still learning things but um as a
recent revert and um you know i uh fired
in uh i forgot your other forgot your
name man
i'm learning name still man oh no
worries my name is romeo rami nice to
meet you um
um as someone that's recently reverted
what would be something that you guys
would recommend for reverts as someone
that's kind of new to it and angel is
there something that you still struggle
with as a recent reverb
martial wonderful question bro so anyone
that just made it on the stream
make some dua for this brother he just
made the best decision of his life insha
allah and his question was any advice
for reverts and if angel is currently
still struggling with anything as we all
are
a year into his reversion so rami who
wants to go first
uh i want to answer mine first because
it's a very concise insha allah join my
class hit us up on ig inshallah you have
ig right
all right perfect hit us up on ig and
just say islam alaikum was the brother
um and was the fitness bibi
and
rami said join my class so i'm down to
jordan sha allah and uh
here you'll get your basic set straight
inshaallah once you have the basics down
you have the fundamentals down you have
the the what's obligatory for you going
everything else is going to be smooth
yeah
yeah man so
first thing i want to say bro
is
congratulations man i know it's a
beautiful thing becoming a muslim
um
understand that it it's like a cloud 9
type feel so that will pass and then
reality will set back in
and the biggest advice i have man is
little by little like don't try to rush
into it
but don't
try to prolong it either because
you know whatever brought you to islam
you should always stay and you should
always understand like well okay this
there's a higher purpose here there's a
higher reason for what you're doing so
anytime you start you know losing faith
or losing
um just motivation to do any studies or
to
look into anything because maybe just
you're not feeling it right
that's the time when you got to go
harder
because that's the time when you're
being tested the most
you know and it's like allah says in the
quran like do they think they say that
we'll believe oh that we believe
and that we won't be tested
you know so
he's little by little
when you feel like you don't want to do
it that's when you got to go harder
and like romney said man learn the
basics
and remember like
this dean bro it's it's the most
important part you know like i was
watching this video last night that hit
so hard where it's like
never forget that we aren't promised
in jannah like we're not promised
paradise
so we should be putting overtime work
you know you had the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam you had the sahaba ready
they were promised jannah and they were
stressed and worried and doing
everything they could
to be better muslims and and just
actually make it to jannah even though
they will promise janna so never forget
that never ease up never take your foot
off the gas pedal because it's not a
game though that's all i gotta say yeah
bro the prophet saw made istafar
repentance hundred or a thousand times
per day the prophet salallahu himself
bro
what excuse do we as the average joe
honestly that's all we are we're just
laymen bro we're just we're just normal
you know mere human beings bro that they
have enoughs to have our desires we're
doing our best with our daily struggles
bro what excuse do we have to not be our
best every day now i get it bro you're
new into this so it seems a little
daunting bro and it's not just because
you're a reaver bro just for anyone
today living in this day and age bro we
all go through the exact same things
that you're gonna go through and that
you've gone through
and that you're currently going through
but my best advice bro
just like wrong uh just like anh said
it's not gonna happen overnight you're
not gonna you know absorb anything
overnight you're not gonna become the
best muslim you can be overnight so
don't make it you know pressure on
yourself to become that overnight but
also don't delay and don't take forever
but bro enough about that man i want to
know more about you what's your story
man if you could you know let's say
let's say this is it this is your
highlight reel you know you get 60
seconds you know
why are you muslim bro i really want to
know
oh man that's a it's a little bit of a
story but i'll try to break it down um
hold up hold up as far as possible
my bad bro
we want you to tell your snippet but we
want you on a video for a reverb
definitely want to know your story the
whole enchilada boy
let's do it man i'm down for it 100
percent
but um
the break it down um just a little bit
essentially along the way
there was just a lot of different hints
of like
like just going to you know kind of just
going back to god you know because as a
kid i never really i grew up kind of
like on the spiritual side not too much
i was leading to a christian but i
wouldn't say i was a full christian it
was just kind of like leaning toward it
but essentially over time there was like
a lot of things that just happened i
could go for like a lot of examples but
one primary example was when i was in
trade school
um it was like around 2014 and uh
essentially like you know in trade in
this trade schools and there was a lot
of the people that were there on the
whim of like
it being their last chance because
people were either being locked up
people were homeless um there was like
courts deciding that they should go to
trade school as one last decision
and for me i was like around a lot of
these people have been in these
circumstances it was kind of like you
know for me it was kind of out of my
comfort zone because i'm more of an
introverted kind of dude but
i'm a little bit different now but
essentially over time it was just like i
felt isolated because you couldn't leave
this campus you had to stay on it the
entire time and there was people even in
prison saying it's like it's just like
prison you can't go anywhere you can't
like do anything you gotta sign up for
trips
but one of the things was is that even
though i felt alone
there was like this uh you know it's a
little bit of a story but nonetheless uh
if you're familiar with j cole the 2014
24 you know 2014 forest hills drive drop
yeah and uh january 28th was one of the
songs i listened to and it in the hook
of that song
was like it touched me it was just like
you know what i mean like it was like
something that said like you need to
just don't worry about it you're you're
in god's hands so i started like doing a
lot of spiritual awakening after that
like looking at different things
but there was a lot of friends of mine
that were muslim and they kind of just
said like just look into it just look
into it just look at it
and over time it was just like
i i have no objections to what i've read
so far and what i've learned from you
guys i've done like a lot of research
but
you guys were like somebody that was
like you know a little bit younger guys
that i could look to and say yeah like i
get like i feel relatable to what
they're talking about so
essentially that's what happens
bro we love you for the sake of allah
and i'm i'm honestly like my mind is
blown the amount of respect i have for
someone like you that despite everything
you've been through
your trials and tribulations bro because
i know it wasn't easy bro definitely um
you know a family that's not muslim and
and all the things all the all the you
know whispers that you got in your ear
bro telling you not to do it and you
don't want to do it there's gonna be a
lot to learn the fact that you still did
it bro you just shut your ego down and
you just took the step that's already
the hardest thing bro do you know how
many people they just wish oh if only i
would have accepted islam oh if only i
would like when time is done bro when
it's all said and done and you can't you
don't have a second shot at it a lot of
people are going to regret so the fact
that you already took that step
now it's just a matter of you know
making the rest of your life the best of
your life bro taking every single day
just take baby steps and just getting
closer to
loving and worshipping our creator
in the way that allah himself wants to
be worshiped
you know what i
i mean that for sure
have you happy those those muslims that
you were around from the beginning but
just before you end it
uh keep keep them around insha allah and
if you don't have them in your life if
you find some muslim brothers keep them
around y'all it's important that you
have us and that you have inshallah the
class that you're going to join but that
you also have the community around you
so
if you can if you're able to get to a
major um you know get there
uh if you have like
drama or prayers together like where you
are now with the brothers
always show up for those insha allah and
stay consistent with the brothers in
childhood
thank you guys i appreciate y'all
baby
we'll be in contact soon we'll
definitely be in contact bro definitely
all right
brothers
thanks for having me uh
yeah i'm a revert from the netherlands i
i reverted i actually
uh
i want to tell you guys a little bit
about my background story and uh ask
your opinion about that is that okay
go for it bro
yeah i have uh i me myself i'm mixed
race i'm i'm half indonesian uh i have
one parent my father that is a muslim
but actually that doesn't make me a
muslim yet
i made my own choice to go deeper into
islam at the age of 16.
i officially converted to islam about
i think three and a half years ago
and actually since last year i made the
choice to actually practicing islam
like uh doing my praying uh ramadan
reading reading out the quran and that
kind of stuff
so actually yeah even though i have a
little bit of a islamic background i
consider myself as a reverb
i think i think there is a difference
between
muslims in canada the united states
and
europe especially western europe where
i'm at now
i don't know if you have noticed that
guys but
i have noticed that especially in the
netherlands
there is a lot of the division within
the muslim community itself
uh
let's think about uh yeah reverts uh the
so-called uh born muslims they uh
whatever they are practicing or not they
have parents that uh are born in a
muslim country
and like
they consider themselves as muslims only
because of the fact that like they don't
eat pork but
they are they do not pray
they are not
doing ramadan they drink they smoke in
some cases they are using drugs in some
cases they are committing xena
uh yeah uh
yeah
i don't know i don't know yeah sorry for
my not the best english guys but
actually the point that i'm trying to
make is like
uh
i made the choice uh to find to find
islam and practice it on my life
like what do you guys think about that
a person that calls himself a muslim but
cannot even speak out a shahadah what is
your opinion about that
well i mean subhanallah when it comes to
a person who claims to be a muslim
but doesn't act as a muslim then i mean
it's only up to allah to say whether
that person is muslim or not and
generally if someone can't even say that
shahadah that's just the stepping stone
to be a muslim so that person wouldn't
be able to they can't say the shahada if
they can't say it you know do they even
believe it
for the people that you know go out of
their way and they commit sins i mean
there's two types there are people that
say they're muslim and commit sins and
they know they're wrong and they repent
and ask allah to forgive them and there
are the muslims that claim to be muslim
and they do these sins they don't know
if they're wrong or they don't care if
they're wrong or worst case scenario
they know they're wrong and they're like
you know
it doesn't matter or they think it's
halal or something and you know
something like zen is clearly haram and
to these people you know there's
a wide range of them you know whether
they know what's wrong or they don't
know they're ignorant or arrogant
and at the end of the day allah
is the only one that can judge them so
as muslims you know you and me
all we can do is you know not shun them
not turn them away give them advice try
and guide them try and bring them back
to the way and establish for them what
muslim truly means what stem truly is
which is
full submission to allah
even though you have these desires and
these things you want to do you put that
aside and you say my desires are not
what is important here allah has told me
the way to live life so i'm going to do
my best to live that way insha allah and
people need to learn that to truly be
muslim
yeah true but uh another example and
like right now i'm all i'm only talking
about the netherlands or western europe
like uh in in the netherlands we have
yeah according to the statistics
we have 1 million muslims
but
those 1 million muslims those are people
that
have an islamic background or maybe have
parents that are from an islamic country
that doesn't necessarily mean that they
are practicing islam actually my point
is uh especially in the netherlands it
is more something cultural instead of
the religion itself
like uh 80 80 or 85 percent of the
of the muslims in the netherlands they
are from countries like uh turkey and
morocco that is the majority of the
muslims in the netherlands but do they
actually practicing it uh
in that 50 or 60 of the cases not
so they call themselves muslims only
because their parents are from a muslim
country
so
in the netherlands and i i am not going
to say all of them but at least
a huge percentage of them for them it is
more something cultural than actually
the rhythm the religion itself and i
think you always should like whatever
you are a christian or a muslim or
whatever
you always put a religion at place
number one and your culture at the
second world because culture
those are
like culture is a lifestyle
uh made by us humans but religion is a
lifestyle and rules made by god our
creator and i think that you should put
that on the first place
and like i am not gonna say that culture
or ethnic background is not important
because that is a part of your identity
but always put religion at the first
place ah that's that's wonderful bro
we actually got to get going because we
got a lot of people in the waiting room
but i just want to tell you exactly what
you said bro you're right bro people got
to put the deen above all else and i
want to say for all of you that have
cultures and you love your cultures
listen if your cultures don't contradict
with islam alhamdulillah but if there's
something in your culture that
definitely you know competes with islam
contradicts islam clashes with islam
definitely don't put it at the expense
of islam put us down first culture
second always salaam alaikum bro thanks
for your time
yeah but i uh i don't know if you guys
have an email but yeah maybe uh
send us an email bro email is the three
muslims at gmail.com bro
all right khalid bro
yeah
i wanted to ask you guys um i mean i
want to ask fayette how did you get
those back plates where are they from
sorry what did i get what
you know the your background the thing
that says alhamdulillah
oh the thicker the the paintings bro
yeah where'd you get them
oh you made them i designed them bro so
i i recommend a lot of you guys now i'm
going to let you in on this bro um i'm
going to be quick too because we got
some people in the waiting room but what
i do right i love supporting businesses
alhamdulillah but bro finding
calligraphy or is so expensive bro it's
like it's really expensive bro so you
know i'm not an expert at graphic design
whatsoever but i took some nice you know
thicker uh images from google you can do
this with another pseudo or anything
else you like um i basically
found a nice background which is this
and i basically just added it as an
overlay and then i contacted one of
those companies where you print
uh anything on canvas right
much cheaper than buying it yourself and
i just sent them the thing in 4k paid it
i think it was like 30 dollars each and
i got three of these it's way better
than spending like three hundred dollars
each which is like typical pro
wow okay thank you
[Music]
did you find the brother
all right bro i guess muhammad didn't
find the brother
inshaallah guys i think we're
approaching you know just over one hour
it was a wonderful first episode of the
live call and what do you guys think
i think it was a great alhamdulillah
honestly i think we should give more
time to people and accept less calls
that's true bro but we gotta find a way
to make it a little more exclusive then
nothing
yeah members only
knobs only you already know
muhammad
salaam alaikum bro
[Music]
okay not sure what's going on with that
yeah it's probably like wi-fi issues or
something yeah we got we got one last
person in the waiting room we got goober
hussein
if you wouldn't mind uh connecting your
devices says device not connected
i just want to give a quick shout out
subhanallah to all the people that
became members today for our youtube
channel and for supporting us
don't think you know it went unnoticed
you know we just had a lot of people uh
in the waiting room and on the chat
but uh welcome to the family
i like this a lot more to be honest the
callings it's more immersive it's
i like just
having the
feedback and the actual conversations
with people
100 100 and to anyone watching don't
think this is going to be like some type
of like group therapy session bro where
it's like you know we're here to bestow
knowledge bro
we ourselves as creators on this channel
might actually gain more from you
hopping on than we then you know you
will gain from us so definitely you know
don't miss this opportunity to come and
chat with us and we'd love to do it bro
we got two more people sophia and ross
marry you guys
i'm the lover i'm doing good
um
does does i3 still do uh those in-class
programs have they been doing them
during their pandemic when you're saying
class do you meet in person or just a
person in person um well because of the
restrictions they haven't i don't think
they've been doing it in person for a
little bit maybe in some places
it's primarily online but i think as the
restrictions go down
the in-person classes will go up and
shut up my my class is primarily
brampton but i don't live there so i
can't do mine there but in the case of
the teacher and the students all live in
one general area which is how they've
organized it this year alhamdulillah and
every year before that
it should be in person over time
okay yeah because i'm from toronto
and i've been to
a class there once um just to check it
out but um
yeah so yeah
anyways
thanks for the tv
so we got one last person gunner hussein
who's actually been on instagram bro
anxiously waiting since yesterday uh bro
if you're trying to join it keep saying
your device is not connected bro
um
also to the girl that's trying to you
know make some inappropriate comments
and lusting for angel
she literally joined the the waiting
room and changed her name to angel as a
snack
listen you want to get angel's attention
bro you got to be respectful you got to
come at it with some with some other
with some
you know if you're trying to haul that
on hell um
he's still single you know just saying
but this is not the way this is
definitely not the way i don't support
this this type of behavior where we
objectify uh human beings especially men
bro this is this has to stop this double
standard in society bro so please you
know you want to reach out to onhub
holla at him but definitely come at it
respectfully
yeah 100 especially on a platform like
this especially on a platform like this
you know we're here
to to preach the dean of allah
and um yeah
all right bro
uh so
gooner said he's gonna be one minute uh
inshallah we're gonna wrap it up real
soon anyway within like two three
minutes
uh yeah bro anyone else want to join
i will paste the link right now you know
this is your one last opportunity
[Music]
uh so basically the point i wanted to
make especially now that
after hearing um a lot of these brothers
talking
it's basically that
i've been through you know me personally
being raised in new york city
i've been through points where i was
ashamed to hide my muslim identity um
going through 9 11
um then being targeted by
you know the blinky people being
targeted by selfies being targeted by so
many people
and then you know
to a point where i was basically almost
like an atheist
then i found islam and i became exactly
what i was running away from where i was
pointing fingers at everyone saying oh a
stuff allah
you're not praying like this or you're
not doing this and oh wow this person is
not muslim enough or this person only
becomes a muslim during ramadan
like ramadan muslim or something so the
point i want to say make basically is to
everyone that
don't take your iman for granted
because iman is a gift from allah you
might have it today tomorrow you might
not
um
that's for x that's a beautiful reminder
although it's a very beautiful you know
and this is a reminder for
people who were born and raised as
muslims who have had their iman go up
and down like roller coaster
and this is for people who have just
become muslims
you know because when you newly start
practicing islam
you feel as if you know you're on cloud
nine or something and then you start
thinking you're better than someone even
if you don't want to but subconsciously
you do that
you know so
before i leave you know that's the same
that's basically what i just want to end
with you know don't take any man for
granted
guys
if you guys made it this far make some
dua for tahir for his wise words insha
allah that allah keeps him on the
straight path
forgives us all
and elevates us all and ahead especially
to the highest rank in jannah i mean i
mean
take care okay
australian reaver
yep
salaam alaikum
um
because the youtube stream's a bit
delayed so i'll try to be a bit quicker
so i've got autism so i don't sound the
best so if i do come across a bit weird
or anything like that because the
the autism so i do appreciate your
patience so it's all good
but i was listening at the start there
to that um sister that wanted to hear
about revert stories and i don't know if
you'd happy to hear my story i'll be
quick because obviously you said you
want to wrap it up and all that um but
all i'm saying is that um basically i
was born i was born baptized catholic um
basically then for years um lapsed
catholic uh agnostic
and then
searching for everything
gone back into christianity and all the
different denominations and all that
long story short there i took uh a
reverted about six years ago because i
looked into islam and it was the only
thing that made sense to me
and um
it's just you know and at the end of the
day it's really you know command one
commandment two it's like
christianity and catholicism was totally
at odds with it and i just couldn't um
make it make sense of it whereas islam
makes total sense to it it's like pure
and monotheism so um all i would like to
say is that um tldr
is basically uh don't despair a bella's
mercy because
yes shirk is um is definitely a major
sin and all that and i was definitely
upon it but judah ella's
he is the most merciful he was able to
guide me to islam because he could see
me in my sincere heart that
you know i was looking for you know the
right path
and so he guided me towards that and
also the last thing is that um with
depression because i suffer with it due
to childhood trauma i won't go into it
but basically
very uh very bad child childhood um
basically mum died when i was 14 then
three years later my dad kicked me out
of the house and it and then i pretty
much from 17 to now where i'm now 40
i've been living alone and just been
trying to to deal with it but basically
um to help me get over the depression i
found that um i because i'm a reverend
and also my memory is not the best
because i did have a motorcycle accident
about four years ago so it's affected my
memory somewhat but i find reading the
quran it helps to focus the mind
relieve anxiety and help like it doesn't
totally cure my depression but
doing salah and reading the quran i find
after doing those things basically for a
short time i have had like a tranquil
heart and so anxiety's um
reduced somewhat sorry i'll let you guys
talk sorry i'm all
so old i'll talk
effectively you you got me you got me
emotional right now bro marshall just
hearing your story bro
it makes me
kind of feel like bro i'm not doing
enough to be honest because just hearing
exactly what you've been through bro and
the fact that allah guided you
my first thing that i want to tell you
bro and to anyone that finds themselves
in a particular in a similar predicament
where you know they're kind of having
some good days some bad days and they're
finding peace with allah and with islam
whatever happened in the past if you've
genuinely moved on from that including
shirk you know doesn't matter we don't
judge what happened in the past before
islam whatever you've done in the past
if you've truly sincerely repented and
you moved on from it you know
it's actually also a sin
to think that allah is not going to
forgive you i know you don't you know
you might not do that but a lot of
people i see this very often they're
like i don't think allah is going to
forgive me i don't i kind of doubt
allah's infinite forgiveness and and you
know all merciful attribute and traits
which in and of itself is something that
we shouldn't do so i'm not going to keep
it long but i'm going to say that you
know alhamdulillah when you when
everything clicks inside you and you
come to the right path and you seek
repentance and you ask forgiveness and
you you genuinely you genuinely make it
your life's mission to just
fully
come to allah and turn to allah and turn
back to allah
then it's it's also good to keep in mind
always to not dwell on okay did allah
forgive me or not
understand if you were sincere allah of
course forgave you and
to keep you know running towards allah
inshallah just be clear i'm i'm
definitely a practicing muslim and i do
my prayers and all that and i also do
some of the dicker so i don't know if
you misunderstood or if i misunderstood
yeah i'm definitely path and try my best
but look no one's perfect and um but
again i i'll let you let me go but
basically yeah we it's a sin to think
allah won't forgive us because he will
he he loves repentance and so it's just
turned into me to repent i'll forgive
you so anyway um
alhamdulillah you have a lovely day and
may i reward you for your good efforts
thank you i mean happy me and you as
well my love going to the highest levels
of jannah bro these few minutes have
been very inspirational to myself and
i love you for the sake of allah i
apologize
inspired them with my story to help them
take shahada and get up on this straight
path anyway have a lovely day thank you
happy birthday
can you guys hear me yeah we can hear it
yeah bro i'm from bangladesh
bro
hello hello bro what'd it do man it's
finally good to have a bengali brother
on the stream bro i must say this is the
first time on youtube or the three
muscles we've got another bengali
brother um as much as i want to speak in
bangla with you bro we're gonna keep it
english bro so everyone else knows what
we're talking about
what makes you want to come on what made
you want to come on the stream today
yeah yeah bro my english is not so good
okay just pardon me um
the thing is that i'm like in your age
okay my age i'm like 24 years old okay
and almost in your ranks so
here in bangladesh a practice becoming a
practicing muslim is really hard you
know
there's cultural issues and if you try
really hard to become a good muslims
your parents gonna say you're becoming
extreme
yeah if you if you're having a beard
they will tell you that you are getting
extreme you're looking very old and you
will not get married
shave your beard this and that you know
and
so it's really hard to be a practicing
muslim and the youth here is
is in a very bad shape you know
so
after watching your podcast you know you
young three young guys so i i try my
best to
encourage the young people like i'm in
instilling the university last semester
and i just gathered the juniors the
juniors who are there the young brothers
and gathered them and told them that
less
less
meet meet up at masjids you know let's
talk let's just like you guys you're
having a good podcast and talking
you know sharing your thoughts here so
we gathered and we went to a mosque you
know and we gathered and talking about
dean with islam the sirat you know he
a old man from the masjid came and told
us you can't be here you can't talk
about dean here get lost when you get
out of the budget you can go go do
something else money
you know
they they think a practicing youth is
extreme he's maybe he's becoming a
terrorist he you know
it's really hard to be coming and
practicing muslims you know in
bangladesh at least
let me tell you this listen you're
singing in bangladesh bro listen i love
bangladesh
20 years ago
i live here
and when people from bangladesh still
find out that you know i'm on dean and
bro the first thing i get
you know yo make sure your sons they're
telling my parents obviously yo make
sure you keep an eye on your son bro
that he's not doing anything to us or or
he's not you know becoming one of the
and i'm like bro
what
you know what i mean it's it's very
sucks and it's subhanallah bro
that
not just bengali culture brought i see
this in a little pakistani culture south
asian culture that
they've reduced the basics of islam
right this makes you a muslim by the way
this doesn't make you a good muslim the
things that make you a basic muslim like
just growing a beard praying salah this
is this means you're radical you're
extreme now you know so this listen we
all know it's fake it's nonsensical
don't let it get to you stay on the
right path bro stay on the straight path
um it's going to be tough bro because
you know culture they want to do
birthdays they want to you know
celebrate christmas even if they don't
believe in christmas day they want to
take pictures and holidays and all this
listen i understand what you're going
through and trust me it's only going to
get harder bro because as we head
towards the end of time uh this stuff is
only gonna get worse bro so all i'll say
is just be grateful to allah that allah
has guided you
and definitely do your best to lead
others if they find your approach to
extreme even if you're doing the basics
at least lead by example bro
never compromise your ways insha allah
and i pray that allah keeps your heart
pure and keeps you on the deen bro
i mean i mean
brothers
i was a bit late my mic wasn't working
so
just managed to stay awake by drinking
some energy drinks man i'm just uh
explaining to you
bro where is it uh you're part of the
world bro
oh uh england bro cambridge okay what
time is it
over here bro it's uh 1 31 bro
a.m
[Music]
so uh sometimes when i can't go sleep i
just stay awake until fajr or sometimes
if i can't then i try and retarget but
you know it's like really good and then
all that listens to you but he comes
through the closest seventh so yeah and
then if i can't sleep you know best
thing to do is just exercise and stuff
and i told uh i'm good brother last time
like i'm practicing shillat so i'll try
and do that as well at home whenever i
can but yeah i hope all of you bro okay
i'm well man
uh my question was just like um well
i've got some like english friends over
here so like they're not like non-muslim
but they're not really good like and
personally to us and everything and they
don't look at something like a bad light
but like what should i say to them when
they're like oh you know
uh on a lot of any phone you can't drink
you can't go to any club you can't even
go and see a woman uh you can't party do
birthday and all this and like uh and
then i told them like
none of this means anything that's just
the test and i try to explain to him
like uh our way like uh we're allowed to
have fun but you know in the hallway and
stuff and then he's like oh that's no
fun man i'm just not like my question
was like how should i tell him like uh
what like um
basically like you know the true meaning
of islam and stuff and try and persuade
them like uh you know one day to convert
inshallah
basically they think islam is boring so
before
one of them they were just like oh you
know basically uh marshall i've never
been drinking or i've even smoked or
even done shish or anything and uh you
know thanks to allan like
from uh they're like oh you never drunk
or you never smoked or you're not living
life bro and then like uh then i told
them all there's no point over there and
they're like just try them and try and
trust me you would know uh that you're
missing out on life and all of this and
then sometimes actually when i was a bit
i'm like in my 20s not like you guys 26
or sometimes i actually think about
trying himself but then uh thanks to
allah my will this strong and i just
pray in the mind and uh i try not to do
that
until now i haven't so yeah
so first thing i'm going to say uh
for your question bro i'm going to keep
my thing short before i pass it on to
the other brothers but we did an episode
with dowie uh michael dawood right so
search up this video that we uploaded
with michael with it's episode 80
something or 90 something i remember and
uh he's basically a british white muslim
revert uh from the uk from luton
england and his story was phenomenal i
recommend you send it um but before i
give it to the brothers i just want to
say real quick the brother malik uh
saying for allah
you know every so often
omar is wondering uh you know who who
it's saying to bro a lot of people just
say
like may allah forgive us may allah
forgive me it doesn't mean anything like
oh brother are stuck for allah
you know so it's probably just something
like that but anyway you guys can uh
carry on
yeah bismillah so
for sharing all of that one thing i want
to say is that you shouldn't put it upon
yourself to guide them because guidance
is from allah whether it's through you
or through someone else
your job is just to spread the deen with
the best of character in the best of
ways and to speak the truth these are
clearly people that value their liberal
physical desires
and you are a person
that
knows you have desires but they ought to
be satisfied in a way that's appropriate
the way that's had
many people who have desires that are
like sexual and all of that that have
things that are like you know illegal
that they they feel like they want to do
and obviously these people have to hold
back so as muslims we just draw the line
a little sooner um as muslims it's not
that we can't have fun uh it's just that
we can't do certain things that they do
for fun and that would just be a
difference in what people find fun but
at the same time our fund is not going
to kill us slowly you know us going to
play some basketball if we find that fun
or chilling and getting you know halal
drinks like friggin drinking orange or
drinking coffee or something that's
gonna be fun for us and that's not gonna
kill us for them
them drinking every night or whatever is
literally slowly going to kill them
at least break them down in a way where
you know they're gonna be a lot less
healthy than they would be if they
didn't drink so you have to tell them
that although they're having this fun
and all of that they have to understand
that this is short-term gratification
and that's not gonna bring them
long-term satisfaction it's not gonna
bring them long-term joy and what islam
is it's permanent like contentment and
acceptance of the truth so that we can
have eternal bliss in the afterlife
yeah well thank you brother i've tried
to i've tried to tell them this as well
but they're like are we all going to die
one day so why not just live life and go
out with the bank yeah because the whole
point of this life is to prepare for the
next one
is is you're going to fall into hell and
and go out with a burden
but what should i how should i come
across it when they don't believe in
hell or anything i mean that's this is a
this is the problem of their their basic
beliefs so first establish the basics
establish that allah exists
establish that um islam is the truth use
the evidences that we have in islam we
have we have an episode talking about
that share that with them
and if they still don't accept habibi at
the end of the day you slowly give dawah
to them maybe they'll accept it if they
don't it's not on you and it's not that
you did something wrong or you weren't
good enough or anything like that the
uncle the prophet saw he was on his
deathbed and the process was basically
begging him to accept islam and he died
without giving a shahada without
accepting islam so the prophet couldn't
do it you know who are we
yes so uh what do you think you know if
you still don't get it then what do you
think do you think i should just cut
ties with them or still like keep trying
if it gets to a point where it affects
you cut ties with them if you're able to
continually give dowell once in a while
without it affecting you then do it but
don't put yourself in that situation
where if they're taking you away from a
stem they're causing doubts in your
heart and they're not going to accept
after hearing the message clearly
you're not obligated to help them if
they don't want it
you don't you don't have to cut them you
don't have to cut them off because i
mean like
you might have to answer to a lot to
that so it's like you it doesn't mean
you have to be with them all the time it
just means like
once in a blue moon like maybe once a
month or once every quarter every four
months of the year just hit them up you
know catch something to eat see how
they're doing and then just kind of like
share what you can in those little
teachable moments and never try to like
say too much you know in regards to what
you're saying like
when they say that
you're not having fun as a muslim
because you're not drinking alcohol well
you gotta
break it down for them and be like okay
well
why do people drink alcohol okay so you
loosen up so you have fun you can enjoy
yourself the thing is alcohol
it it actually
makes you
feel like a better words it makes you
[ __ ] because it's it's
listening bro listen to this is
lessening your inhibitions
right you have less inhibitions so now
you are more free you're you're speaking
in a way that you would speak with
people who are very close to you and you
could be speaking this way with people
who you have no idea who they are so
people like these people like to have no
inhibitions but the thing is that the
inhibitions are there for a reason you
know now of course like you're not just
gonna have zero inhibitions all the time
because we live in we live in a world
where not everyone has the best of
intentions
all right now
these people
if they depend no no no i'm going no i'm
gonna meet you because you're echoing
all right
okay so
what i was saying
is that these people who drink alcohol
they do so because they want to get rid
of these inhibitions was like
you're basically using this as a crutch
you're using the alcohol as a crutch
because you're saying well i can't enjoy
myself sober so i'm going to use the
alcohol to enjoy myself i can't speak to
people sober so i'm going to use the
alcohol to speak to people like this
like i said it makes you [ __ ] and
then that that's called the tipsy stage
that only lasts so briefly before you
pass that point of no return and now you
are drunk now it's like
well you have no control now something
else is in control if you know what i'm
talking about and then in regards to
like
we or
shrooms or acid or any of this other
stuff that these people might be doing
like
these are all things that are
able to be experienced naturally
so for them to say that you're missing
out
is an ignorant statement because if you
can experience it naturally
how would you be missing out you would
be missing out if you could never
experience what people experience on
these things on these substances
that would be missing out but the fact
that you can experience it naturally
without having to come down without
having the side effects
makes it all the better
so if anything they're the ones missing
out because they have to go through all
the side effects through all the come
downs and have this constant
these are highs and lows highs and lows
highs and lows when it's like you can do
it naturally you can be on the straight
path and you can continuously
go higher and get into that the highest
state achievable as a human being
naturally and a lot bro so
that's all my drop my drop that's it bro
go no bro i'm just gonna unmute right
now
yes uh thank you yes sir
yeah thank you for that bro that's
really nice but uh i i've kind of like
tried to tell them these kind of things
but yeah then i get what you mean
although like uh i'll try and do like
more with uh you know just not cut them
off and stuff uh but even though when
i've told them before like with all this
you know they're like oh you don't get
with guild you don't do drugs like
mainly they don't do like none of the
crazy stuff like heroin or anything
don't need to read and that's their
argument like oh bro man it's just weed
it's not gonna kill you or anything it's
just like and they go actually cures
their depression because i've uh since
i've done a bit of research on my mates
most of them like when they're depressed
they do it and we're not trying to you
know try and get them to uh uh most of
them are atheists themselves they don't
actually believe in anything they just
uh i don't know what they believe in but
they don't believe in any god or
anything and they think there's no life
after death so they're just like why not
just you know do whatever you want and
uh
so yeah but i will try and you know try
and come across with what you said as so
but yeah but the argument is like you
know uh we're all gonna die one day so
why not just you know chill
so yeah and they keep on doing that so
sometimes i'll get influenced as well
i'm like marshall i still haven't done
now but i'm always scared that um the
devil might you know tempt me one day uh
you know to do one of them things but
inshallah just pray for me
in sure
yeah allah i'll try my best for and i
always keep all three of you in my doors
and stuff bro and i hope you stay on the
right path and uh keep doing your good
work bro and i love all of you guys
all right that's a wrap to episode one
of our live call-in show guys i think it
went a little better than i expected
yeah
that was really good it's really good
one of the takeaways that i want to
stress is
said
you know more quant more quality less
quantity so definitely it's probably
going to be something like members only
or patrons only or something like that
it's not again less quantity
more quality yeah
more quality more quality
i mean more quantity and quality that's
that's the goal bro but for now more
quality
and not necessarily quantity you know
what i mean
um who's gay definitely all of us
brought this way but insha allah that's
that was a joke guys that was a very
terrible joke also um
forgive us bro um but that being said uh
smash the like button if you made it
this far comment down below what you
thought of this this is just something
new we're running if you want to keep
this up
probably going to be members only or
patrons only just you know not not for
you know the money or the clout none of
that literally just because we have so
many people we literally still have
brothers and sisters in the waiting room
right now but we can't because we're
literally out of time
but we need to make a way for people to
like
genuinely come and be serious you know
what i mean
a lot of people and i've seen this
happen to a lot of channels people just
come just speak nonsense alhamdulillah
we didn't have anyone today that did
that or spread hate or something like
that and most of the time if people are
doing this they have too much time on
their hands bro they're not going to
want to commit or invest in in you know
us or anything like that so that being
said stay tuned every single monday and
friday 7 00 p.m eastern standard time uh
which will be around midnight uh in the
uk
and around 7 00 a.m tuesday and saturday
for the eastern countries like thailand
malaysia uh indonesia and so on
and if the brothers don't have anything
else to say insha allah we can wrap it
up
bye
with that being said
oh wait sorry i know do you have
anything to say bro i i didn't make sure
i just i wanted to know what uh the beef
was
yo
we ain't ending the stream bro until you
let us know what the beef was
malik bro
it's gonna be more than 400 likes no cap
but you got to let us know now no cap
let's go
it's not we're not we're not being
aggressive or anything malik we're just
we just genuinely want to know bro what
the beef was
yeah i'm curious bro
malik is ferociously typing right now
i'm struggling with some person when i
clicked on one of his videos and he said
if you're slipping you'll be just being
up
yeah hey what was the truth bro
what's the truth sometimes
you gotta have people to tell you how it
is even if
it's not what you want again
you know maybe you know when i said it
that time like i was you know a little
jot him
still john but um
yeah bro
man
i just want to say to our lovely 134
viewers that made it this far just like
angel said sometimes the truth hurts
being among the majority is not always
the best thing especially in today's
time um
make us of the few right and i said this
last episode i'ma say it again
being of the few like the brother from
bangladesh said it's not always the
worst thing bro it might feel that way
because in the dunya being of the few
you know
everyone thinks you're weird you're
different you know you look different
you'll come across different everyone's
doing this you gotta leave five times a
day to make your salah it seems scary
definitely but
trust me you're not going to regret on
the day of judgment you're going to
thank allah that he guided you and that
you were one of the few inshallah
[Music]
inshallah
i guess with that being said we'll end
it
for joining inshallah we'll see you guys
on the next one
foreign